this video is all about one man over in
motel aka the red Viper who slithered
onto our TV screens and into my heart
during season four of Game of Thrones
hey guys it's Dan here for flicks and
the city delivering a hot combination of
badass quips and nifty moves on the
battlefield and in the bedroom over in
charmed our socks off so we never wanted
him to leave but leave us he did and
perhaps the most shocking moment of
season four so far so in over ins honor
I've dedicated this corner of the
Internet to the best on-screen moments
of our favorite prince poet lover
fighter and father played by the
peerless hetero Pascal by the way if
it's your first time here I do tons
exclusive interviews with the Game of
Thrones cast weekly reviews of the
latest episodes and top Game of Thrones
lists so if you haven't already do
subscribe okay let's take a look at my
countdown of the top five over in
Martell moments hating an early morning
starts because he prefer the late night
sessions not standing up when the Kings
hands high when entered the room the
whole way he sat in that chair and
commenting on the unsullied prowess on
the battlefield compared to the bedroom
could this scene be any more Oberyn and
I just love how he comes across so in
contrast to mace Tyrells toadying around
Tywin the Dornish duo Oberyn and his
lover Ilario sand got busy with a bed
full of beauties of both sexes in
episode 3 raising the show's boob
invitamos er and delivering some
delicious dialogue who can forget that
perfectly Oberyn moment when he
explained his sexuality to Littlefinger
spy and prostitute Oliver when it comes
to war I fight for Dorne when it comes
to love I don't choose sides
and what about Allari about standing
reply to Oliver when he asked over and
if he managed to [ __ ] his fill before he
got old he's a prince of Dorne girls and
boys will line up to [ __ ] him till the
day he dies but it wasn't long before
Tywin barged into the room bringing an
end to the fun and frolics apparently
nobody knocks in King's Landing then
Tywin made over in an offer he couldn't
refuse a chance to meet the mountain
returned for Oberon sitting on a small
Council and acting as a third judge at
Tyrians trial for Joffrey's murder I
love this verbal dance between Tywin and
Oberon for many reasons including the
fact / and invites tiring to sit down on
the bed where he's just been having an
orgy the way / and nonchalantly admits
to be an expert in poisons despite the
fact Tywin's Branson's just been
poisoned and the way he stares down
Tywin after he categorically denies his
involvement in the murder of over and
sister Elia and her children over in
like things his way as he told Oliver
when we first met him in the king
blending brothel so our Dornish Prince
wasn't best pleased when he heard the
sounds were little Lannister ditty in
the air as he was getting ready for a
bit of slap and tickle now if there's
one thing you really didn't want to be
caught doing around Oberon it was
singing the rains of castamere sadly for
his wrist satin pink little Lannister
man didn't receive that memo so when he
decided to sing his heart out and insult
over into he's soon found himself on the
receiving end of some friendly Dornish
advice about long swords being a bad
option in close quarters out that's
gotta hurt Oberyn Martell the fastest
draw in Westeros after bran turned down
the opportunity as championing Tyrion in
his trial by combat the red Viper
stepped up to save the day
well yeah that bit didn't quite go
according to plan but Aaron's heart was
certainly in the right place even if his
face wasn't by the end of his match
against the mountain in a cracking
performance from Pedro Pascal we learned
that Oberyn Martell visited Casterly
Rock
not long after Terry was born that
Cersei hated her younger brother even
then and that to Tyrians family he was
nothing but a monster but Oberyn
obviously started telling it like it is
from a young age was when he saw baby
Tyrion for the first time his response
was that's not a monster
that's just a baby Oberyn Martell you
sir were an absolute boss it's just a
shame that in the end Tyrion was right
that Oberyn had come to the wrong place
for justice but you'll always be our
champion Oberyn
how could anything else snatch the
number one spot but oberyn's valiant
attempt to topple the mountain oh how I
wish I didn't have to use the word it's
helped in that last sentence but a fatal
combination of cockiness and obsession
ensured the red Viper was off to meet
his maker yes just in case you're in any
doubt george RR martin has shown it yet
again just why we absolutely cannot get
attached to any character in the game of
thrones world still when ilaria implored
over and not to leave her alone in this
world I kind of half wanted him to burst
out into song ain't no man either to
keep me from getting to you except maybe
that mountain yes that faceoff was all
brilliantly perfectly overran it starts
with a glass of wine and a kiss with his
lover ilaria then continued full of
Blair SAS and uber confidence plus a
dogged determination to get the mountain
to confess to the heinous crime of
raping and murdering his sister Elia and
her children pal over an evil manager
spear Gregor in the gut and the leg
before the mountain made mincemeat of
our favorite Dornishmen over and overand
overand overand if only today had not
been the day you died to see where that
brutal clash between Oberyn and Gregor
ranks in my top Game of Thrones face
offs of all time check out my video here
so what are your favorite over Martel
moments did you tear up when you saw him
lose to the mountain let me know in the
comments below don't forget to subscribe
so you don't miss out on more top fives
coming up as well as episode reviews and
exclusive cast interviews and remember
if you're not watching Jan G on G ot you
know nothing
you